coming up next week at the Stars burg
plenary alcohol control plastic bags
European cinema e condemnation of Boko
Haram welcome to the agenda no more
excuses that was a mess from the EU
foreign affairs chief federica mogherini
as a death toll from the latest tragedy
of the Mediterranean Sea creeps up past
eight hundred just in the first few
months of 2015 alone over 1,700 migrants
have died this week in Brussels EU
leaders hastily convened an emergency
summit and on Wednesday any peace will
vote on their own measures to try to
save lives bring back our girls was at
the campaign that even got the support
of viewers first lady Michelle Obama but
a year on the 300 shoe box all girls are
still missing as a burger mom continues
to wage its campaign of killings
kidnappings and rape what can be done
the Nigerian Army has been unable to end
their six-year insurgency and with so
much regional instability Africa
neighbors like resources to lend their
help so what can you offer on the last
day the plenary any Peas debate a
million of them are used every minute
they're the most common found rubbish
after cigarette stubs for the end of the
plastic bag is in the making 2019 it's
bye-bye to the free plastic bag as new
rules will impose a mandatory pricing
Europe white citizens will also face and
90 bag yearly limits it goes to plenary
for a final vote on Tuesday does your
night on the tiles involve you
strategizing whopped & howell drink all
Europe to is about to get its own
alcohol strategy the drawbacks are
drinking a pretty straightforward weight
gain a general lowering of regional
behavior also commonly referred to as
stupidity but on the higher end of the
scale it can lead to addiction and death
at the plenary MEP debate measures to
reduce alcohol abuse on Wednesday as
they try to push for new legislation the
lux prize winning film ider also to comb
and
skur the brits film the imitation game
was also oscar-nominated but still us
blockbusters dominates the european film
market so whats the remedy the 3ds
distribution digitalization and of
course de niro three things that could
help reinvigorate the european film
industry on tuesday em ups will look to
pass a resolution to give the industry
more backing and don't forget that eco
will get its final roll call at the
plenary on tuesday and at second
generation biofuels will get another
push on wednesday and as all we have
this agenda take care and enjoy the week